20 MAY 27, 2020.
GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY, TUCKER IS
NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE WILL HAVE THE LATEST ON THE
RIOTS IN MINNEAPOLIS LAST NIGHT
AND YES, THEY WERE IN FACT RIOTS
NO MATTER WHAT THEY ARE TELLING
YOU ON THE OTHER CHANNELS.
THAT’S A FACT AND WE HAVE THE
TAPE.
FIRST TONIGHT WE WILL STATE THE
OBVIOUS.
DONALD PROMPT TWEETS AN AWFUL
LOT AND MANY WISH HE WOULDN’T DO
IT.
WHETHER IT’S POLITICALLY WISE
FOR THEMSELVES TO DO THIS,
DONALD TRUMP HAS AN ABSOLUTE
RIGHT TO EXPRESS WHAT HE
ACTUALLY THINKS.
EVEN IF OTHER PEOPLE ON EARTH
DISAGREE WITH HIM.
THAT’S WHAT THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT, THE FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
SADLY IT’S BECOMING A MUCH LESS
FREE COUNTRY LATELY.
ANY TIME IN THE PAST HUNDRED
YEARS AT LEAST AND THE PEOPLE
WHO WIELD THAT POWER HAVE NO
INTEREST WHATSOEVER IN THE RIGHT
TO SAY SOMETHING THEY DISAGREE
WITH.
IN FACT THEY ARE DELIGHTED TO TO
SILENCE YOU IF YOU TRY.
TWITTER FOR EXAMPLE NOW OPENLY
PURGES USERS WHOSE POLITICAL
VIEWS, AND IT’S BEWILDERING THAT
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO DO THIS.
BECAUSE LIKE ALL THE TECH
COMPANIES, TWITTER ONLY EXISTS
BECAUSE TWITTER ENJOYS KEY
EXEMPTIONS FROM FEDERAL LAW.
IN THE WHITE HOUSE DOES, TOO.
AND YET THEY’VE DONE ABSENTLY
NOTHING SO FAR TO HELP YOU.
UNTIL YESTERDAY TWITTER RETURNED
THE FAVOR BY LEAVING THE
COMMANDER COMMANDER IN CHIEF’S
TWITTER FEED ALONE.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED THAT MAIL
IN BALLOTS COULD BE
"SUBSTANTIALLY FRAUDULENT.
AS A FACTUAL MATTER THAT IS TRUE
AND WE CAN PROVE IT.
AS WE TOLD YOU LAST NIGHT,
MAIL-IN BALLOTS HAVE BEEN LINKED
TO NUMEROUS CASES OF ELECTION
FRAUD.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN CONVICTED FOR
IT.
SO IT’S NOT REALLY UP FOR
DEBATE.
THIS IS NOW THE CENTRAL
OBJECTIVE OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND SO YOU ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO KNOW ANY OF THAT.
YESTERDAY TWITTER PLACED A
SO-CALLED FACT-CHECK ON THE
PRESIDENT’S TWEET."
TRUMP FALSELY CLAIMED THAT
MAIL-IN BALLOTS WILL LEAD TO A
RIGGED ELECTION.
FACT-CHECKER SAY THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE THAT MAIL-IN BALLOTS
ARE LINKED TO VOTER FRAUD."
AS A FACTUAL MATTER, THAT IS LAW
AND THERE IS NO OTHER WAY TO
INTERPRET IT.
BUT WORSE THAN A LIE IS
POLITICAL CENSORSHIP.
SO WHO DECIDED TO DO THAT?
WELL, THEO OR REALLY ENTITLE
HEAD OF SITE INTEGRITY, ON
TWITTER.
AN IRONING FREE ZONE WHERE THEY
DON’T UNDERSTAND THAT THE TITLES
ALONE ARE SCARY.
NOT SURPRISINGLY, ROTH IS A
POLITICAL ACTIVIST.
IN JANUARY 2017, ROTH COMPARED
KELLYANNE CONWAY TO THE
PROPAGANDA JOSEPH GOEBBELS.
THAT SAME DAY HE RE-HE REFERRED
TO THE PRESIDENT’S NEW STAFF AS
ACTUAL.
AND A LOT MORE, AND THESE ARE
THE PEOPLE CONTROLLING, THEY ARE
AUTHORITARIAN.
IF THEY SENSE OF THE PRESIDENT
THEY WILL THINK NOTHING AT ALL
OF SILENCING YOU AND THEY DON’T
COME THEY WOULD GLADLY DO IT.
THEIR JOB WAS TO SAFEGUARD THE
FIRST AMENDMENT WHICH WAS
DESIGNED TO PROTECT THE WEAK,
NOT THE STRONG, THE WEEK ARE
PROTECTED BY THE FREEDOM OF
SPEECH.
THEIR READERS AND VIEWERS.
THEY WEREN’T SUPPOSED TO BE
SIMPLY THUGS HIRED TO PROTECT
THE POWERFUL BUT THAT’S WHAT
THEY HAVE BECOME.
WATCH DON LAMONT OF CNN WHO IN
HIS DEFENSE OFTEN HAS NO IDEA
WHAT HE’S SAYING TRYING TO BULLY
TWITTER INTO SENSE AND THEY CENS
IDEAS THEY DON’T CARE FOR.
>> TWITTER WOULDN’T REMOVE THOSE
TWEETS.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN REMOVED FROM
TWITTER FOR FAR LESS OUTRAGEOUS
BEHAVIOR.
COME ON, JACK DORSEY.
>> STOP HIDING BEHIND THE
FIRST AMENDMENT FOR PROFIT.
STOP DOING IT.
DO THE RIGHT THING.
STOP HIDING BEHIND THE
FIRST AMENDMENT SAYS DON LAMONT.
IN THE ANNALS OF CABLE NEWS THAT
MUST BE THE MOST UNINTENTIONALLY
HILARIOUS LINE EVER UTTERED BY A
SCRIPT READER, AS IF EXERCISING
YOUR GOD-GIVEN INBORN RIGHT TO
SPEECH AND THOUGHT AND
CONSCIENCE IS SOMEHOW WRONG.
IT’S IMMORAL.
DON LAMONT DEMANDS A STOP
THINKING FOR YOURSELF.
GET ON BOARD AND OBEY, UNTIL THE
PARTY LINE OR WE WILL HURT YOU,
THAT’S HIS MESSAGE.
THAT’S A MIRROR IMAGE OF WHAT
JOURNALISTS SHOULD BE SAYING.
THE ONLY REASON WE HAVE A FREE
PRESS ARE, IT’S ONLY ONE AND
THAT’S TO FIGHT BACK AGAINST
AUTHORITARIAN POWER STRUCTURES
THAT DEMAND WE READ FROM
APPROVED SCRIPTS.
AND NOW CNN IS WRITING THE
SCRIPTS, IT’S TERRIFYING.
ALL OF A SUDDEN IT’S EVERYWHERE.
THROUGHOUT APRIL AND MAY,
YOUTUBE THROUGH GOOGLE TOOK DOWN
AND ANY PART OF A VIDEO THAT
EXPLICITLY -- RECOMMENDED
GUIDANCE.
IF YOU DARE TO QUESTION THE
DECREES OF THE POLITICIANS, SOME
OF WHOM WERE IMPRESSIVE AND WISE
AND MANY OF WHOM WERE DUMB AND
MAKING THINGS UP AS THEY GO
ALONG, BUT IF YOU CRITICIZE THEM
THEY WERE CENSORED.
FACEBOOK CEO MARK ZUCKERBERG
RECENTLY EXPLAINED WHY
CENSORSHIP WAS NOT REALLY BAD.
IN FACT IT SAVES LIVES.
>> INFORMATION, AND IF SOMEONE
IS SPREADING SOMETHING THAT
GIVES PEOPLE THE RISK OF
PHYSICAL HARM THEN WE TAKE THAT
DOWN AND WE DON’T ALLOW THAT ON
FACEBOOK.
IT IS ALSO OTHER MISINFORMATION
THAT MAY NOT LEAD TO PHYSICAL
HARM, BUT IT ISN’T THE TYPE OF
STUFF WE WANT TO BE SPREADING TO
OUR SYSTEM.
THEY ANNOUNCED THE IDEAS MUST BE
THROWN INTO THE FIREPLACE AND
FORGOTTEN FOREVER.
AND YOU CAN IMAGINE WHO’S ON THE
PANEL, A LIST OF POLITICAL
ACTIVISTS AND AN AGGRESSIVE
OPPONENT OF FREE SPEECH.
AND THAT’S A RHETORICAL QUESTION